so rudy giuliani is complaining that the  doj covertly got access to his icloud  without notifying him and  if it can happen to him it can happen to  anyone well yes if the doj had probable  cause then they can serve a warrant on  the service provider  with an order that says that they can't  disclose the fact that they got access  to that information or alternatively  this might not have been a search  warrant there's something called a  national security letter that's an  administrative subpoena that doesn't  give you access to the content of  something but it does give you access to  metadata like file names or  subject lines for emails and yes it's  true that it's rare for the crime fraud  exception to overcome the attorney  client privilege but that might be  what's happening here so  who knows maybe we'll see rudy giuliani  in court